I got a chance to sit in to a lengthy
brainstorming session with Tyler and
others that was really cool
can you talk about the process of that
of uh
people pitching ideas
and you pitching Alternatives or
shutting down ideas and just going like
plowing through ideas very good I mean
you kind of just described exactly what
we did yeah I mean but the ideas are
really really good it's just tossing out
like different categories of ideas and
then also fine-tuning them to see like
you know I changed like thinking about
the titles and the thoughts I work so
well off of inspiration it's like that's
a something
like give give me anywhere I don't know
like a real face space yeah like I went
to space you know what happens if you
blow up a nuke in space or I went to the
moon I went to Mars right because you
said that one word it was able to
inspire me to come up with four ideas
and so that's just it's for me
if you the way to get 100 million views
on videos you need something original
creative something people really need to
see ideally never been done before all
these like things and so you need like
if you want to consistently go
supervisor you need just a constant
stream of ideas and the only way I've
really found that I can consistently
come up with 100 million view videos is
to intake inspiration and then see what
my brain outputs and so that's kind of
at its core Foundation what I'm doing
there it's just like in taking a lot of
random inspiration to see what spawns in
my mind so I can output it but the
neural network of your brain is
generating
the video the title the thumbnail all
that jointly exactly and that only comes
because I spent 10 years of my life just
obsessively studying all that stuff
because you I mean it seems like you
would literally potentially shut down a
video just because you can't come up
with a good title yeah or a thumbnail
yeah I mean that's what happened to 70
of those in that pitch session I was
just like oh what was one of them genius
versus 100 people or yeah like maybe
average intelligence versus genius yeah
I was like what the heck is the
thumbnail even if the title was good
yeah yeah I mean there's so many but
yeah people don't click they don't watch
that's so interesting but you developed
over time the ability to kind of give it
what what makes for a good title short
not just short it's also I mean
if someone reads it are they like do
they have to watch it is it just so
intrinsically interesting that it's just
gonna [ __ ] with them if they don't click
on it you know what I mean so it doesn't
have to be short but it has to be
like you almost want to have a retention
to word by word reading ideally it's a
title also that
um you know because the titles don't
live in a vacuum right so it has to lead
into the content so ideally the title
represents content that you would want
to watch for 20 minutes so if it's a 20
minute video and the title is I stepped
on a bug it's not gonna because it's all
of it combined it's the click-through
rate is going to be much lower and then
if it was like a five second video
people might click it so you gotta like
even nuances of the length of the video
based against the title will affect
whether people want to click it because
sometimes they just all add up I mean
it's that yes ideally you want to blow
50 characters because above 50
characters on certain devices you run
the chance of it going dot dot dot so
like I took a light pole and I saw how
many dollar bills I could stack on top
and they would just go dot dot dot
because it's too long and it can't
finish it and that's the worst thing
because then people don't even know what
they're clicking on and so it's going to
do even worse
um short simple ideally and just so
freaking interesting they have to click
and it is a good segue into the content
and represents the length of the content
and there's probably stuff it's hard to
kind of convert into words for you like
I stepped on a bug versus stepping in a
bug versus Mr B stepped on the bus
steps so it's like yes the more extreme
the opinion typically the higher the
click-through rate if you can like uh
pay it off in the content then it just
supercharges it so like oh so you have a
kind of estimate of the experience this
water right if you're like
Fiji Water sucks yeah that would do fine
but if you said Fiji Water is the worst
water bottle or the worst water I've
ever Drank In My Life yeah way more
extreme opinion would do way better but
you have to deliver yeah but then you
have to deliver because the more extreme
you are the more extreme you have to be
in the video yeah that's almost
inspiration for you to step up yeah but
you can you can be more extreme in a
positive way a lot of people it's easier
though
pause it
uh negative clickbait is much easier
than positive Cliff it just is it's so
much easier to get Negative clicks and
so a lot of people are just in my
opinion you know a little bit lazier and
they just take the route like oh well
this one gets the same amount of clicks
and it's easier less effort the positive
one is doing a large number of numbers
of something like I I spent this number
of hours doing this but whatever if you
just wanted to help people or right it's
just harder to get 10 million views on a
video helping people than it is to get
10 million views on a video tearing down
a celebrity you know what I mean or
whatever negative video you want to
insert there well that said most of your
videos are pretty positive so what's but
not a lot of people do those kinds of
videos because they're hard yeah they're
hard some of that is giving away money
right yeah
um what's the secret to that what's how
do you do do that right yeah like give
away money or in a video that made to
make it compelling
um is it so there's a number that is
better than another number right the
higher number is always better than the
other number yeah for the most part and
you know it's interesting like some
videos will give away a million dollars
some videos will give away half a
million there's not really I guess so
I'm retracting what I just said I was
more joking with that but there's no
difference whether I put 500k or a
million it's probably not even really a
difference between 100K a million I
haven't really looked into it like some
of our mostly videos are not us giving
away a million dollars and sometimes the
million dollar videos just don't do as
well as the other ones so there there's
a certain point where a dollar amount is
just a large dollar amount to an average
human and so I think that point is 100k
like anything above 100K the average
human's just like that's a lot of money
you know it doesn't it doesn't 100K in a
million like it doesn't really move the
needle if that makes sense which that's
a very nuanced piece of information that
applies to very few people but yeah well
no I think it applies it's fascinating
it's fascinating human our relationship
with money is fascinating like why is it
so exciting to get
I mean I you know the times I found like
20 bucks in the ground are like
incredible really I don't know why right
why why are you so happy like what
exactly is so joyful about that I mean
it depends where you are in life what
the situation is yeah I don't know
there's also a gamified aspect to it
it's exciting yes no I get it like why
people want to see people win money it's
just interesting that past 100 Grand
it's it doesn't really seem to make a
difference like it's the same basically
so you found that to be true with all
the money you've given away that I just
didn't click through it like obviously
in terms of someone receiving it yeah a
million dollars changes their life
drastically more
like that's the difference like oh you
if you wanted to you could really quit
your job as opposed to 100K is like not
really you probably do like a scientific
study like a formula giving away money
to click-through rate yeah there could
be some kind of difference it definitely
the the returns level off dramatically
after 100K that's basically the premise
what about ten thousand uh no there's
ten a hundred thousand is that it's
funny because this is such a small Niche
thing but yeah a hundred thousand does
it from what I see in our videos get
more clicks than ten thousand but the
difference between a hundred thousand
million is just so little I just I think
big number big number to a lot of people
I passed that point yeah so for a
hundred thousand you can like give an
average salary you could probably live
for a year given given a day out average
salaries in America so that's like a big
that feels like yeah I think it's also
just more when they read the title it's
just like it's a lot of zeros [ __ ] loads
of zeros Okay click yeah
[Music]
oh man that's fascinating so on the
thumbnail side again that's going to be
much harder to say probably
um but you know offline you know I got a
chance to look at a bunch of thumbnails
and it's fascinating which ones do well
and which ones don't is there something
you could say about what are the
elements of a thumbnail that work well
is this also deeply insane well that's
where yeah it's the same thing like how
do you cook good food but um it's easier
if you pull up a thumbnail that could be
like that's why that's good that's why
that's bad that's uh like an example
would be like one of my friends I was he
just uploaded a video recently and I
called him I was like what is this
because he's a very very smart guy and
then the thumbnail he's he's getting
chased by cops but the cops are wearing
yellow vests so they didn't look at cops
I was like whoa why are the cops in your
thumbnail wearing yellow vests it's like
that makes it so much more boring and he
was like carrying a flag but the poll
and the color of the flag were the same
color so it's like it's a lot harder to
see the flag I was like also you're
wearing like a shirt with like five
different colors like so it's like it's
hard to tell what even what your outline
is and then in the background there were
cars and I was like oh if you have cops
chasing you why not make the cars cop
cars and you know and it's like because
in my head I'm like ding if he just did
those like four or five things the video
probably got like seven next the views
how much iteration because I also got a
chance to see the number of iterations
you do on a on just it's a problem now
it's an addiction is it so you kind of
there's a lot of the versions were
really good yeah how do you know when to
like I love how you when we pulled up
that uh the burger one and we were
flipping the room you're like that's
really good I was like oh that's version
like one of like a thousand but even the
sketch the idea was good like already
even the original idea is strong yeah so
we one of our coming up videos we made
the world's largest plant-based burger
and the thumbnail we were thinking is
like me standing beside the bird because
it's six feet tall that's that's what
he's talking about so like just picture
a giant six foot tall burger super wide
thousands of pounds and then I'm beside
it and then it's like eating the world's
largest burger like you that's just
something you have to click like so you
were saying like how would you describe
a good thumbnail like that you know what
I mean like but I think you said the one
I noticed first that was good where you
were very small in it relative to the
and you didn't like that one I needed to
come forward a little bit and also the
photo we took was uh just my upper body
so they photo manipulated and created my
legs Photoshop and that's why I said I
didn't like it because my right leg was
a little like off it was like bit the
wrong way
does the physics and the thumbnail have
to even make sense I mean you can just
like exaggerate the head size and all
that kind of yeah 100 yeah things don't
have to be relative yeah you can have a
car in the background be three times the
size yeah because yeah every one of my
thumbnails my face is in the you know
left side very big so brand recognition
so just people know oh especially
because now that a lot of people copy
our videos it's just nice to like you
know everyone else might make thumbnails
like this but this is mine and obviously
we usually over deliver and do bigger
stuff